[Music]
yes
i'm walking on beverly and fuller and
there's a black guy he's flashing a gun
around he's pointing at these
construction guys and he's walking on
beverly and like pool they're going to
princeton he's wearing a blue sweater um
beverly and fuller
yeah and he's walking towards the
poinsettia he's wearing a blue sweater
and he saw me so he put the gun inside a
like a bag but 100 he has a gun 100
and now he's walking up on beverly
he's going up towards the la he's
passing poinsettia right now i'm like a
block away from him
but color is the fact that he has a gun
in
uh it's like a food bag he only has one
bag with him
but this guy's crazy he's got he
kind of got issues uh you're talking
yourself and informing me if i can catch
you guys he saw me he put it in his bag
and he walked past me and then he pulled
it out again on arrival to the
intersection of beverly boulevard and la
brea avenue officers located the suspect
standing on the sidewalk the suspect was
later identified as john blocker
blocker produced a handgun and fired at
officers at which time an
officer-involved shooting occurred
blocker ran west on beverly boulevard
stopped turned back and fired at
officers again resulting in a second
officer-involved shooting blocker then
ran north on the 300 block of detroit
street where he laid down on a porch and
was taken into custody a portion of this
incident was captured by surveillance
video from a nearby business
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
blue sweatshirt
[Music]
beverly suspect male male black blue
sweatshirt
[Music]
six a fifteen shots fired
six eight fifteen fifteen
we're going to be at the virginia
detroit
and beverly running northbound on
detroit
isn't it
i am south berlin
hollywood
two blocks
north two blocks west and east
see
6 815 he's wearing a blue shirt black
pants carrying a
tan bag
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
he's good enough good enough
[Music]
get it
[Applause]
is
um
[Laughter]
now good well this is the opportunity
right now
we're going to make the approach
now during this back and forth
[Music]
oh
[Music]
do not move
go outside to the police department do
not move